we have now uh artificial intelligence
perception we're talking about a lot
we're talking about the second cambrian
explosion in
in in perception and what's so
interesting is that when
when like a fleet of teslas
is driving and then the
the tesla one of them goes through a
very specific
pattern of activity that they that
the collective intelligence that had not
experienced before
what happens is as soon as that tesla
goes through that process
of learning from that unique novel
experience
what it does immediately is it updates
the collective database of all
tesla's knowledge so i love that
analogy in a sense of how fast a
collective intelligence of artificial
intelligence perception can learn
and there's some sort of analogy there
with humans especially that we can
scientifically test
how is it that if somebody learns
something across the planet
that somebody else in a different
country across the planet can
learn that faster
yeah yes well um yeah i agree the
this artificial intelligence thing which
has this built-in learning
which is shared um is a bit like morphic
resonance and
collective memory and that's why it's so
powerful of course
if you just rely on a programmer
programming things with no learning
um then you know they get it right they
get it wrong it works some of the time
but this one actually learns and adapts
as
new situations arise and that's much
more like evolution and much more like
the collective memory
in morphic resonance